Now in this course so far, we've seen a ton of different equations involving two
variables. Things for example like y equals 3x plus 2. Now equations in two
variables can express input and output, causing effect or some sort of other
relationship involving dependence. The note seemed like the two variables in the
equation would each play a different role. Perhaps it's that one of these two
variables needs to depend on the other. Now just like in this equation right
here, a lot of the other equations we've seen at different parts of the class,
have been written in the same form. As y equals some sort of expression
involving x. We saw that we could write quadratics in this form too. And there
were a lot of situations in which isolating y by itself on one side was really
conveinent for solving for different quantites. Now those equations were all
written in the form y equals some expression where x is the variable. And if we
have an equation that's written in this form, which of these three statements
down here do you think is implied? In an equation like this does x depend on y?
Does y depend on x? Or, is there no relationship of dependence between x and y?
In other words, does one of these two quantities help determine the value of the
other one?